we are learning more about a school
shooting in St Louis where two people
were killed and seven more were injured
yesterday the suspected gunman is also
dead in a scene that is sadly all too
familiar students were seen running out
of the high school with their hands
above their heads as anxious family
members waited nearby in a parking lot
authorities say police shot and killed
the gunman at the scene Damon Arnold
with our St Louis affiliate KMOV has the
latest Damon is outside of the school
this morning Damon
good morning to you David I'm outside of
Central vpa High School where the doors
are shut there will be no students here
classes have been canceled and
rightfully so as somebody who was here
yesterday first on the scene witnessing
students run out in pure chaos telling
me that they had guns shoved in their
face asking them if they were ready to
die or they had to jump out of windows
to try and escape the trauma that
they're suffering today only makes that
decision the right call today now we're
remembering here in this community the
loss of a teacher that 61 year old Gene
kuchka and 15 year old Alexandria Bell
you see a growing Memorial behind me and
it is this Memorial that is fueling the
investigation that now has the FBI
trying to figure out the motive behind
this gunman
we heard these gunshots and the windows
just rattling and we see people jumping
out the windows and stuff students
describe chaos as the shooter who
authorities say was armed with a long
gun open fired at Central Visual and
Performing Arts High School it recorded
the active shooter in high school police
say that that call came in around 9 11
Monday morning four minutes later police
say law enforcement arrived on the scene
by 9 23 they say officers engaged the
suspect in a shootout and by 9 25 he was
dead I think my friend have all blood on
her hand and it was like she seen the
shooter and the shooter came to her and
said you ready to die
students will evacuated to a nearby
grocery store parking lot where they
reunited with their families police
later identified the shooter as a 90 row
who graduated from the high school trust
last year he lives in the 9 000 block of
Pennsylvania with family members and he
has no prior criminal history
[Music]
people from across the St Louis
Community gathered to mourn the victims
Monday night including Alexandria Bell
and PE teacher Gene kuchka who died at
the hospital it's kind of unreal to
think that she's gone like when I
literally just saw her be like the other
day
um
she was just the sweetest lady officials
didn't reveal how the gunman got into
the building but said school security
and existing safety protocols helped
delay his entry our school had metal
detectors the doors stay locked there's
security guards all over the place and
somehow still this was able to happen
and now this community just tries to
figure out how to move forward and to be
okay sending back to you Bill
all right Damon you're right it's sadly
all too familiar
thank you very much